[Música]
en Brasil cuatro menores muertos y
cuatro hospitalizados es el fatal
balance que dejó un ataque con hacha en
un centro de preescolar en el sur del
país el atacante de 25 años Fue detenido
por la policía el presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva calificó los
hechos de monstruosos
el presidente francés está en China
frente a la comunidad francesa en
Beijing Emmanuel macron ha destacado el
papel que puede jugar China para
alcanzar la paz en Ucrania uno de los
temas centrales que abordará con una
reunión bilateral este jueves
noche de alta tensión en Jerusalén este
la policía de Israel cargó con granadas
y gases contra las personas que oraban
en la mezquita de alaxa durante uno de
los rezos nocturnos del ramadán el mes
sagrado de los musulmanes las fuerzas
israelíes detuvieron a cerca de 400
personas
Buenos días bienvenidos las noticias de
Franz 24 en español seirosa Pérez más
deu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
Brasil donde un hombre armado con un
hacha ha matado al menos cuatro menores
y ha herido a otros cuatro en un centro
de preescolar en el estado de Santa
Catarina en el sur del país la policía
ha detenido al atacante de 25 años que
habría accedido a la escuela escalando
Las paredes del edificio los menores
heridos de entre 3 y 5 años están
ingresados en el hospital de blumenao la
localidad donde ocurrió el ataque el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva ha calificado los hechos de
tragedia inaceptable y acto de odio y
cobardía y ha expresado sus condolencias
a las familias de las víctimas
no hay mayor dolor que el de una familia
que pierda a sus hijos o nietos más aún
en un acto de violencia contra niños
inocentes e indefensos mis condolencias
y oraciones a las familias de las
víctimas y la comunidad de bloominado en
medio de la monstruosidad ocurrida en la
guardería a un pastor
vamos ahora a China donde se encuentra
ya el presidente francés Emmanuel macron
para su primera visita al país desde
2019 un viaje coordinado con la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
bonder Legend que también está en
territorio chino los mandatarios
europeos intentan acercar relaciones con
el gigante asiático en torno a dos
cuestiones principales por un lado
reforzar lazos económicos y por otro
convencer a Beijing que use su vínculo
estratégico con Moscú para alcanzar la
paz en Ucrania O al menos evitar una
escalada nuclear nuestro corresponsal
Adrián foncillas con los detalles
el presidente francés Emmanuel macrón ya
está en China donde pasará los próximos
tres días con una doble finalidad por un
lado estrechar las relaciones económicas
para lo cual se ha hecho acompañar de
una nutrida representación de 60
empresarios y por el otro intentar
convencer a China para que contribuya a
acabar con la guerra en Ucrania gracias
a su buena sintonía con Rusia china
puede jugar un buen papel en el camino
hacia la paz ha dicho hoy macron el
presidente francés se reunirá mañana con
su homólogo chino y ambos partirán al
día siguiente hacia la provincia sureña
de One Esta visita forma parte de la
iniciativa diplomática China de
recuperar el tiempo perdido después del
parón de casi tres años por la política
del cero covid Y es que la diplomacia
china vive en un Frenesí en apenas unos
meses habrán pasado por aquí entre otros
el presidente de España Alemania y
Francia y los más altos dirigentes de
las instituciones europeas ese afán de
China por estrechar los lazos que en
Europa contrasta con el desdén por tener
la comunicación con Estados Unidos
después del escándalo del supuesto globo
espía a Pekín le urge por un lado alejar
a Bruselas de la línea hostil de
Washington y por el otro sumar adeptos
para su plan de paz para Ucrania lo
segundo no va a ser nada fácil el
presidente español Pedro Sánchez Ya dijo
aquí la semana pasada que el plan que
apoyaba era el de Ucrania porque era el
que estaba conforme a la carta de las
Naciones Unidas y la presidenta de la
comisión usa la ponderle que está esta
semana con macron en Pekín calificó el
plan de paz chino de inviable y
precisamente en Rusia durante una
ceremonia televisada celebrada en el
kremlin en que los nuevos diplomáticos
presentaron sus credenciales Vladimir
Putin echó en cara a la nueva embajadora
estadounidense en Moscú que Washington
es culpable de la situación actual en
Ucrania por haber apoyado la llamada
revolución del euromaidan en 2014 Putin
achacó la crisis entre Rusia y Estados
Unidos a visiones distintas sobre la
formación del nuevo orden mundial
las relaciones entre Rusia y Estados
Unidos de las que dependen directamente
la seguridad y la estabilidad mundial
atraviesan Lamentablemente una profunda
crisis el uso de herramientas de
política exterior por parte de Estados
Unidos como el apoyo a las revoluciones
del color y el apoyo al golpe de estado
en kiev en 2014 al final condujo al
actual crisis de Ucrania
y entre tanto follodi mix de lensky
refuerza Los lazos con uno de sus
principales aliados Polonia el
presidente ucraniano se encuentra en
territorio polaco para su primer viaje
oficial al país desde que empezó la
invasión rusa durante su Estancia
selenski ya se ha reunido con el
presidente y con el Primer Ministro
polaco recordemos que desde que empezó
la guerra Polonia ha recibido a miles de
ucranianos desplazados por el conflicto
y que además Varsovia ha impulsado el
envío de armas pesadas a
diez en otras noticias en Francia
fracasó la reunión entre la primera
ministra Elizabeth Von y los sindicatos
acerca de la impopular Reforma pensional
el gobierno no está dispuesto a dar
marcha atrás con la reforma después de
aprobarla por decreto el movimiento
social ha criticado repetidamente la
falta de diálogo del ejecutivo Y es que
el de hoy de hecho fue el primer
encuentro entre el gobierno y la
intersindical desde que empezó el
movimiento contra la reforma hace meses
de hecho ya hay nuevas movilizaciones
convocadas para mañana
encontramos un gobierno radicalizado
obtuso y desconectado es una bofetada a
los millones de franceses y francesas
que están en la calle que están en
huelga que se oponen a la jubilación a
los 64 años a la ampliación de la
cotización y a la supresión de los
regímenes especiales de pensiones y en
Italia el líder de fuerza Italia y tres
veces Primer Ministro hablamos de Silvio
berlusconi se encuentra interesado en
cuidados intensivos en el hospital de
San Rafael de Milán centro en el que ya
estuvo tres días hospitalizado el pasado
mes de marzo según informó la televisión
pública Italiana la raid el ex
mandatario y empresario de 86 años se
encuentra en situaciones estable Aunque
ingresó en el centro médico con
insuficiencia respiratoria recordemos
que el partido de berlusconi forma parte
de la coalición de extrema derecha del
gobierno de Georgia
en otros temas esta noche la represión
de las fuerzas israelías contra la
población Palestina cobró la forma de
una redada en la mezquita de alaxa con
granadas y gases lacrimógenos la policía
de Israel cargó contra las personas que
rezaban en el templo durante una de las
oraciones nocturnas del ramadán el mes
sagrado de los musulmanes la actuación
de la fuerza pública de Israel y ha sido
condenada por la autoridad Palestina o
por jamás o por países como Egipto o
Jordania recordemos que sobre el papel
custodia los lugares sagrados tanto del
islam como del cristianismo en Jerusalén
estas imágenes difundidas por la policía
israelí muestran cientos de fuegos
artificiales explotando mientras las
fuerzas entran en la mezquita al Axa de
Jerusalén en la madrugada del miércoles
las personas que se encontraban adentro
del lugar de culto afirman que fueron
agredidas físicamente por los agentes
israelíes
la policía israelí no se atacó allí
dentro todos los jóvenes que están
dentro están sufriendo y nadie les ayuda
qué esperan atacaron a todos los que
estaban dentro todas las ventanas de la
mezquita están rotas
[Aplausos]
la violencia se produce casi a mitad del
ramadán y cuando los judíos se preparan
para celebrar la Pascua judía la policía
israelí ha emitido un comunicado
tratando de justificar las acciones de
los oficiales esta noche mientras la
policía trabajaba para permitir que un
gran número de musulmanes celebraran el
mes del ramadán varios jóvenes forajidos
y agitadores enmascarados introdujeron
fuegos artificiales palos y piedras en
la mezquita tras largos e infructuosos
intentos de sacarlos mediante el diálogo
la policía se vio obligada a
desalojarlos para permitir que tuvieran
lugar las primeras oraciones del Alba y
evitar disturbios violentos el incidente
ha recibido la condena internacional
tanto de Egipto como de arradia Saudita
Esta última ha declarado que socava los
esfuerzos de paz en la región tras los
enfrentamientos se dispararon varios
cohetes desde el norte de la franja de
gaza hacia el territorio israelí el
grupo palestino jamás denunció lo que
calificó de Crimen Sin precedentes los
cohetes palestinos provocaron una rápida
respuesta aviones de combate israelíes
atacaron gaza a primera hora de la
mañana del miércoles según jamás los
ataques alcanzaron dos campos de
entrenamiento uno en la ciudad de gaza y
otro en un campo de refugiados
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con más información en France 24 y
France 24 punto com
[Música]